[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ihr wisst ja, ich lebe im schönen Baden-Württemberg,
bin stolze Badenerin.
Der Murat kommt aus dem Schwabenland,
aus Württemberg,
durfte aber bei uns hier einziehen
und ich habe ihn auch sehr gerne.
Bei uns hier in Baden,
also im Süden Deutschlands
ist es wirklich wunder-wunderschön!
Wir haben immer tolles Wetter.
Wir haben ein tolles Klima.
Wir haben eine tolle Landschaft,
schöne Natur
und wir wohnen direkt an der Grenze zur Pfalz.
Und die Pfalz ist auch wirklich wunderschön!
Auch ich als Badenerin fahre da gerne hin,
esse dort
und wir machen auch gerne Ausflüge dorthin.
Und die Pfalz,
die hat was ganz Besonderes.
Die hat nämlich auch ein ganz tolles Klima.
Und dort gibt es jedes Jahr den Spargelstich.
Richtig ganz feierlich.
Und dieses Jahr ist es zum 17. Mal soweit
und ich darf den Spargelstich feierlich
mit dem Hartmut dort machen.
Heißt das, ich bin jetzt die Spargelkönigin, Josh?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: So mit so einer richtigen Krone?
Ich glaube schon.
Die badische Spargelkönigin fährt in die Pfalz
und macht den Spargelstich!
Das machen wir jetzt heute.
Und zudem gibt es vom Pfalz.Marketing
dann noch ein Preisgeld.
Wie hoch das ist und wofür es verwendet wird,
zeige ich euch gleich.
Jetzt fahren wir erst mal schön in die Pfalz rüber.
[Musik]
Jetzt sind wir hier in Mutterstadt angekommen
in der wunderschönen Pfalz.
Ist auch wirklich nur ein Katzensprung von uns entfernt.
Man sagt doch immer so schön:
"Die Pfalz ist die Toskana Deutschlands."
Denn hier gibt es den besten Wein,
den besten Spargel.
Hier gibt es ganz viel frisches Obst und Gemüse.
Und heute werde ich den Hartmut besuchen
hier auf dem Spargelfeld.
Er wird mir zum einen zeigen,
was das Besondere am Spargel ist,
was die Unterschiede zwischen grün und weiß sind,
wie man den Spargel perfekt verarbeitet,
und ich möchte ihn momentan auch mal fragen,
wie es ihm denn so geht.
Denn die Landwirte sind halt wirklich
immer die Leidtragenden.
Die müssen sich praktisch
schon Anfang des Jahres überlegen:
Was kommt den dieses Jahr schon wieder auf uns zu?
Eine Hitzewelle?
Schädlinge?
Ernteausfall?
Haben die Pflanzen genügend Wasser?
Aber die Landwirte sind halt wirklich diejenigen,
die jeden Tag für euch auf dem Feld stehen
mit ihrem Team,
die Erntehelfer brauchen
und die einfach dastehen und dafür sorgen,
dass wir frisches Obst und Gemüse aus der Region haben
ohne Flugwege,
pestizidfrei, schadstofffrei.
Und deswegen, finde ich, sollten wir
die Landwirte auf jeden Fall unterstützen.
Dahinten steht schon der Hartmut mit seinem Sohn.
Und den besuche ich jetzt.
Und dann lernen wir etwas über Spargel und können schauen,
was wir als Konsumenten für die Landwirte so tun können.
[Musik]
Hallo, Hartmut!
>> HARTMUT: Hallo, Sally!
>> SALLY: Ich bin heute da,
um ein bisschen was über den Spargel zu erfahren,
wie man Spargel sticht
und...
>> HARTMUT: Also für dich jetzt als Erklärung:
Beim Spargel sagt man immer, man sticht die Spargel.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> HARTMUT: Die Spargelwurzel selbst wird ja
mit dem schönen Erdhügel so bedeckt,
dass man eine schöne lange Stange hat.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> HARTMUT: Und dass man die dann natürlich
dann nicht komplett ausbuddeln muss,
hat man immer die langen Messer.
Inzwischen hat man sie hier mit einer v-förmigen
Kerbe vorne dran, dass man auch schön an dem Spargel
dann reinstechen kann
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> HARTMUT: und es gut abgeschnitten wird.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> HARTMUT: Man muss deswegen nur einen Teil ausgraben,
gucken, wo der Spargel ist.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> HARTMUT: Dann geht man mit dem Messer unten rein
und mit dem Zack, mit dem guten Stich dann
kann man sie eben abschneiden.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Also kann ich mir die Spargelpflanze so vorstellen,
das sind nicht einzelne Stängel
wie so eine Blume, die hier wachsen,
sondern eine große Pflanze unter der Erde.
>> HARTMUT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und da wächst dann immer wieder
der frische Spargel raus.
>> HARTMUT: Man sagt, Spargel kann man sich jetzt
so ungefähr so vorstellen wie eine Hand.
Man hat außenrum die Wurzeln
und in der Mitte in der Knospe treibt es dann immer wieder
eine Stange nach der anderen.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> HARTMUT: Das ist dann eben auch das Typische,
wo man bei dem Spargel sagt,
es sollte ein geübter Ernter sein,
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> HARTMUT: dass er nicht beim Ernten von einer Stange
an die Stange nebendran mit dem Messer
einen Ritz reinmacht,
die dann halt,
ja, nicht mehr so schön aussieht,
teilweise dann irgendwann,
ja, verworfen wird, entsorgt werden muss.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Und wie kann ich mir das vorstellen?
Wie groß ist da jetzt so eine Spargelpflanze?
>> HARTMUT: Also eine ausgewachsene Spargelpflanze,
die hat es schon so
und kann einen Schubkarren vollmachen
mit der Wurzel.
>> SALLY: Oh, okay.
Also da sieht man irgendwas dann.
Auch so den ganzen Damm von der Breite her,
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> HARTMUT: wie man ihn heute mit der Maschine
schön breit machen kann,
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> HARTMUT: es kommt überall in den Wurzeln
ein Spargel dann raus.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> HARTMUT: Wir können mal vorne drangehen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> HARTMUT: Dann kannst du das mal direkt angucken
>> SALLY: Perfekt.
>> HARTMUT: und darfst dann auch gern mal probieren.
>> SALLY: Ja, machen wir.
Also da sehe ich schon den ersten Spargelkopf.
>> HARTMUT: Richtig.
Das sind die Sachen, wo man jetzt heute natürlich
– man sagt auch immer, Plastik im Feld.
Das hat nichts anderes damit zu tun,
dass wir die Spargel auch nur einmal am Tag ernten müssen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> HARTMUT: Früher hat man immer so schön
nach den Rissen geguckt im Feld:
Wo ist so eine Spitze, die unter der Erde anfängt zu schieben?
Heute macht man sich es einfach.
Wir sind ja auch faul.
Wir sagen, wir gucken,
da, wo der Spargel direkt steht,
geht man dann immer mit den Fingern
– da sagt man so schön "die Zwei-Finger-Technik" –
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> HARTMUT: an der Stange rein,
macht eine Kuhle,
dass man sehen kann,
wo die Spargelstange
im Damm nach unten geht.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> HARTMUT: Dann nehme ich jetzt mein Messer
und
führe es jetzt so an der Stange nach unten,
möglichst halt senkrecht, dass ich ein bisschen tiefer komme,
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> HARTMUT: halte dann die Spargel fest
und dann steche ich einmal tief rein.
>> SALLY: Dann hört man es schon im besten Fall.
>> HARTMUT: Ein zweites Mal.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> HARTMUT: Und dann habe ich hier die Stange
schön in der Hand.
Aber du kannst ja gerne auch mal selbst probieren.
>> SALLY: Ich probiere auch.
Ja.
Ich sehe jetzt hier schon
drei Spargelstangen.
Die eine ist ein bisschen schief,
aber ich probiere mein Bestes.
>> HARTMUT: Schön entlang runter.
>> SALLY: Schön tief.
>> HARTMUT: Und jetzt mal um die Kurve nach hinten weg
und draufdrücken auf das Messer.
Reinschieben. Ja.
Besser noch mal nachstechen.
Sehr gut.
>> SALLY: So.
Meine erste Spargelstange.
Nicht gerade,
aber schön.
Warte. Kontrolle.
>> HARTMUT: Prima.
Spargel, kann man fast sagen,
zwischen 5 und 6 cm wächst eine am Tag.
>> SALLY: Wow!
>> HARTMUT: Deswegen kann man schon gucken,
wenn man beim Ernten irgendwo eine kleinere sieht,
dass die...
>> SALLY: Soll ich die jetzt noch drin lassen?
>> HARTMUT: Die müssen wir jetzt einfach mit rausnehmen,
weil du hast ja hintendran noch mal die nächste,
die du ernten möchtest.
>> SALLY: Ja. Okay.
Das ist nicht so einfach, wie es aussieht.
Ich erinnere mich ja an ein Spargelstechen in Österreich,
aber ich habe es nicht mehr so anstrengend in Erinnerung.
Ta-daa!
>> HARTMUT: Prima.
>> SALLY: So.
Sieht doch gut aus.
Und ihr erntet praktisch einmal am Tag?
>> HARTMUT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> HARTMUT: Die Spargel kommen dann
nach Hause bei uns,
werden dann auch in Eiswasser schnell runtergekühlt,
was dann die beste Qualität ist.
Hier hast du eine Kelle.
Die kannst du einfach nehmen
und dann die Erde ein bisschen wieder
>> SALLY: Ja. Das ist jetzt wieder mein Part.
>> HARTMUT: nach oben transportieren.
>> SALLY: Wie das Tortenbacken.
>> HARTMUT: Man macht ja einfach die Kuhle wieder zu,
dass die nächsten Stangen dann wieder
schöner mit Erde bedeckt sind.
>> SALLY: Und der ist ja immer richtig frisch.
Was morgens geerntet wird,
wird schon am gleichen Tag auf dem Spargelhof
im Laden verkauft, gell?
>> HARTMUT: Ja.
Die Spargel kommen heim, kommen in die Kühlung.
Man will ja die beste Qualität erhalten.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> HARTMUT: Deswegen kommen sie dann auch
auf die Waschmaschine, werden sauber gemacht.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Wo hast du jetzt gesehen, wo der drin war?
>> SALLY: Die Spitze hat rausgeguckt.
>> MURAT: Kann es sein, dass du zu lange brauchst?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ja.
>> MURAT: Hartmut, das sind halt die Leute,
die beim Spargelstechen helfen wollen
und nichts bringen, gell?
>> HARTMUT: Aber man könnte sagen,
es war jetzt eine superschöne Stange.
Die ist absolut gerade.
Die ist gut abgestochen.
Die ist lang genug.
Also
mach sie nicht so schlecht.
He, jetzt brichst du sie ab.
>> MURAT: Ich habe jetzt oben das abge-...
>> HARTMUT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das ist doch das beste Stück!
>> MURAT: Echt?
>> SALLY: Natürlich!
>> HARTMUT: Ja.
>> MURAT: Braucht man auch gar nicht sauber machen, gell?
>> HARTMUT: Nee.
Es knirscht vielleicht mit dem Sand ein bisschen,
aber rohe Spargel sind auch sehr gut.
Also als Rohkostsalat kann man sie gut mit reinmischen.
>> SALLY: Du kriegst später einen Rohkostsalat.
Also dann stechen wir jetzt noch ein paar Spargel fürs Team,
bringen den Spargel mit nach Hause
und dann wird er daheim zubereitet.
>> MURAT: Schmeckt super!
>> SALLY: Magst du ein bisschen einen Spargel stechen?
>> MURAT: Komm. Einen mache ich mal. Okay?
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> HARTMUT: Bitte schön. Es darf jeder.
>> MURAT: Danke.
>> SALLY: Hier, schau mal.
>> MURAT: Ah, gefunden!
Ich habe zwei gefunden!
>> SALLY: Zwei auf einen Streich.
Oh, jetzt habe ich die Spargelspitze abgetrennt.
Siehst du.
Ich steche ihn trotzdem raus.
>> MURAT: So.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wo der ist.
>> SALLY: Du musst ein bisschen noch weiter.
>> HARTMUT: Du musst ein bisschen aufgraben,
dass du die Stange siehst, wo sie unten rauskommt.
>> HARTMUT: So. Und dann...
>> MURAT: Und jetzt so rein?
>> HARTMUT: Nicht so nah an der Stange.
Einfach
ein bisschen Abstand. So.
Und jetzt drehst du das Messer hinten rum.
Halte mal die Stange vorne weg
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> HARTMUT: und drücke drauf.
Wenn sie nicht...
>> MURAT: Ah, jetzt habe ich sie abgerissen, glaube ich, gell?
>> HARTMUT: Ja, ein bisschen.
>> MURAT: Nee, ich bin...
>> HARTMUT: Jetzt hast du noch eine. Da probier noch mal.
Ein bisschen weiter runter, dass er lang genug ist.
>> SALLY: Also wir sind echt Spargelanfänger.
>> HARTMUT: Und jetzt unten umdrehen und ab.
Noch mal nachstechen.
>> SALLY: Nicht abreißen!
O Gott! Hör auf! Nicht abreißen!
>> MURAT: Kaputt. He, he.
Stell mich bitte nie ein.
Wirklich. Dann bist du pleite.
>> HARTMUT: Ja. Also ich glaube, das braucht
noch ein bisschen Schulung da, bis das was wird also.
>> SALLY: Oje!
>> MURAT: Das ist jetzt auch, glaube ich, eins.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, Hitzewelle, Ausfälle, Ernteausfälle,
das ist alles nichts gegen Murat auf dem Feld.
Der macht euch das ganze Feld kaputt.
>> MURAT: Dieses Jahr war die Ernte nicht so gut.
Der Murat war auf dem Feld.
[Musik]
>> SAMIRA: Was ist das Tim?
>> TIM: Also das ist eine Pumpe.
Damit kann man Wasser aus dem Boden pumpen.
Da stellt man einfach hier so einen Traktor hin
und dann
noch eine Zapfwelle hinten dran,
also da dran,
und am Traktor ist auch noch so was.
Und am Traktor schaltet man das dann halt an.
Dann dreht es sich schnell.
Dann kommt da aus dem Boden das Grundwasser,
geht dann dahinten raus,
wie man hier die Rohre sieht.
Das ist jetzt nicht verbunden.
Aber dahinten spritzt es jetzt halt.
>> SAMIRA: Ah, okay.
>> ELA: Okay.
>> SALLY: Jetzt haben wir nicht nur
leckeren, frischen Spargel aus der Pfalz,
sondern auch noch vom Pfalz.Marketing
2.500 € bekommen für unsere Stiftung als Spende.
Vielen Dank!
>> LANDRAT KÖRNER: Gut.
>> SALLY: Da freuen sich die Kinder und Familien.
>> LANDRAT KÖRNER: Ja, für die neue Küche.
Helfen dürfen wir ja nicht.
>> SALLY: Ja, gibt es eine neue Kindergartenküche.
Also denkt dran.
Jeder Spargel, der bei euch auf dem Teller liegt,
dafür hat man sich einmal gebückt, den Spargel gestochen.
Esst den Spargel wirklich sehr bewusst!
Ja.
Ich habe heute vielleicht
ein bisschen was dazu beigetragen,
ein Anfang ein bisschen.
Danke schön.
>> HARTMUT: Aber man sieht, was es für eine Arbeit ist
mit dem Spargel.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> HARTMUT: Man sieht genauso,
dass man natürlich dann auch irgendwo
später auf dem Teller oder beim Einkaufen
natürlich darauf achten sollte, dass es aus der Region ist,
um den regionalen Bauern mit zu unterstützen.
>> SALLY: Auf jeden Fall!
>> HARTMUT: Die beste Qualität bekommt man eben,
wenn man sie jetzt gerade morgens geerntet hat
und dann mittags gleich mit nach Hause nehmen kann.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> HARTMUT: Du wirst deinen natürlich
wahrscheinlich jetzt mit heimnehmen wollen
und direkt mal probieren können,
was du dann da alles geerntet hast.
>> SALLY: Den machen wir jetzt sofort zu Hause.
Also seid gespannt drauf.
Jetzt fahren wir wieder nach Waghäusel
und bereiten leckeren Spargel zu.
[Musik]
Und jeder regionale Landwirt
hat ja auch normalerweise einen Hofladen.
Dort könnt ihr euch die Erzeugnisse
meist sogar die ganze Woche kaufen.
So unterstützt ihr die Menschen und die Region
und ihr habt zudem noch die beste Qualität
und das Ganze tagesfrisch.
Ta-daa!
Frischer Spargel vom Feld!
Einmal habe ich jetzt hier
den ganz normalen weißen Spargel.
Und dann
habe ich noch Suppenspargel mitgenommen.
Der ist nämlich schön dünn.
Und ein Qualitätsmerkmal von frischem Spargel ist
– ich meine, wenn ihr es bei eurem Landwirt vor Ort kauft,
müsst ihr das nicht machen.
Aber
hier, wenn ihr die Stangen aneinander reibt,
dann quietschen die!
[Quietschen]
Ta-daa!
Also
Suppenspargel ist ganz dünn.
Denn der muss hier oben gar nicht geschält werden,
sondern wirklich nur hier unten.
Und die Spargel vom Bauern vor Ort,
die sind einfach so frisch,
dass ihr nicht diese trockenen Enden unten habt.
Am besten ist es auch immer,
ihr verarbeitet ihn direkt am gleichen Tag.
So habt ihr die volle Frische, das volle Aroma.
Wenn ihr aber sagt, ich möchte jetzt auch Spargel kaufen
für morgen und übermorgen vielleicht,
dann könnt ihr ihn einfach in ein feuchtes Tuch einwickeln
und im Kühlschrank lagern.
Man kann ihn sogar einfrieren.
Dann könnt ihr ihn schon mal schälen
und zum Beispiel einvakuumieren
oder einfach in einen Gefrierbeutel geben,
einfrieren und dann habt ihr auch im Winter was davon.
Denn die Spargelsaison
geht leider nur bis Mitte/Ende Juni.
Man sagt auch: "Stich den Spargel nicht nach dem Johanni."
Also nach dem Johannistag im Juni
wird er nicht mehr gestochen,
weil dann einfach die Spargelpflanze wachsen darf,
um eben dann auch Nährstoffe
für das nächste Jahr zu haben,
dass im nächsten Jahr eben auch die Ernte gut ist.
Ja,
so viel eigentlich zum Spargel.
Ich werde jetzt hier gleich
zum einen Spargel ganz normal zubereiten
– ich habe jetzt nur den weißen mitgenommen –
und dann eben auch mal eine Spargelsuppe machen.
Die machen wir gleich im Anschluss.
Zuerst einmal zeige ich euch jetzt,
wie man diesen Spargel verarbeitet.
Also da ist wirklich wichtig,
wenn sie frisch sind,
dann muss man hier unten fast gar nichts wegschneiden,
nur 1 bis 2 cm,
und den Spargel natürlich schälen.
Grüner Spargel, der muss gar nicht geschält werden.
Denn der ist einfach ganz knackig und ganz frisch.
Und man kann Spargel roh essen,
gebraten, gekocht, gedämpft, gebacken,
in der Pfanne zubereitet.
Und das ist wirklich alles Geschmackssache.
Ich werden den jetzt hier gleich dampfgaren
im Backofen in meinem Dampfgarer
und dazu eine Hollandaise machen,
eine Sauce Hollandaise,
einmal die klassische Version
und einmal gleich die vegane Version.
Am besten nehmt ihr euch jetzt einfach einen Spargelschäler.
Viele Hofläden bieten aber auch geschälten Spargel an.
Also man kann hingehen, sich den Spargel aussuchen
und direkt schälen lassen.
So machen wir das auch meistens.
Und dann lasst ihr hier oben den Kopf weg,
den muss man nicht schälen,
setzt den Schäler an
und schält die Schale weg.
Die hebe ich dann gleich noch auf.
Denn die könnt ihr wirklich super noch benutzen,
um noch mehr Geschmack
in eure Spargelsuppe zu bekommen.
Ihr könnt ihn auch einfach flach hinlegen.
[Musik]
Spargel gehört wirklich zu meinen Lieblingsspeisen,
gerade jetzt so im Frühjahr/Sommer.
Zum einen, weil er mir sehr gut schmeckt,
und zum anderen, weil er sehr gesund ist,
vitaminreich ist und pro 100 Gramm nur 20 Kalorien hat.
Ist wirklich wie ein Fitnessessen,
wenn man nicht gerade die Sauce Hollandaise dazu isst.
Aber ich mag Spargel ganz gerne auch im Salat
oder als Suppe oder vom Grill
und da braucht man dann auch echt nicht viel dazu.
Und ich meine, ihr kennt den Murat.
Murat ist ja wirklich so der Fleischesser schlechthin.
Und ich kriege es auch selten aus ihm raus,
dass er so sagt: "Okay. Heute mal kein Fleisch."
Aber, wenn es bei uns Spargel gibt,
dann verzichtet er auch gern auf Fleisch,
weil er sagt, okay,
Spargel ist für ihn so wie so eine Art Fleischersatz.
Und man rechnet so ungefähr
500 Gramm Spargel pro Person,
wenn nicht sogar bis zu einem Kilo
für gute Esser.
Und je nach dem eben,
was ihr noch als Beilage oder als Vorspeise habt,
könnt ihr wirklich so einiges an Spargel rechnen.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt hier noch Kartoffeln geschält
und werde jetzt bei mir
den Spargel und die Kartoffeln dampfgaren.
Ihr könnt aber auch den Spargel
ganz einfach im Topf kochen mit etwas Wasser,
eine Prise Salz und Zucker dazu.
Und dann ist es wirklich eine Geschmackssache:
Mögt ihr ihn etwas weicher
oder mögt ihr ihn etwas bissfester?
Es gibt auch extra Spargeltöpfe,
wo einfach der Spargel
so darin gegart wird.
Da ist dann...
Also der wird dann so hochkant reingestellt
und der Topf ist dann etwa so hoch.
Dann füllt ihr ihn etwa so weit mit Wasser.
Das kocht dann
und der Kopf des Spargels,
der wird dann praktisch dampfgegart.
Und der ist ja immer schneller durch als hier unten.
Und daher wird er dann einfach nicht matschig.
Ich werde es, wie gesagt, dampfgaren in meinem Backofen,
nehme jetzt aber den Spargel raus,
weil die Kartoffeln jetzt länger brauchen.
Ich halbiere die jetzt noch,
schiebe schon mal die Kartoffeln in den Backofen
und dann kommt
der Spargel gleich dazu.
Oi, hast du ein Geschenk für mich?
Was ist das?
>> ELA: Verrate ich dir nicht.
>> SALLY: Oh! Ich...
>> ELA: Du musst es aufmachen!
>> SALLY: Ich mache es auf. Sofort.
Moment.
Also die kommen jetzt in den Backofen.
[Musik]
Ah, ich habe noch Wasser drin.
Oder?
Ja, das müsste reichen.
[Musik]
Ich mache jetzt mal 20 Minuten.
Und dann kommt der Spargel gleich dazu.
[Musik]
Oh, Ela!
O mein Gott!
Ist das Herz für mich?
>> ELA: Für die ganze Familie.
>> SALLY: Ojemine, mein Schatz! Oje!
Danke!
Gel öpeyim!
Weißt du was?
Das kommt jetzt...
Ich tu es gleich...
Darf ich es in so eine Pflanze dann rein machen?
>> ELA: Ja!
>> SALLY: Okay, in die Küche drüben.
>> ELA: Mama, ich habe es für eine Pflanze gemacht.
>> SALLY: Ich mache es jetzt mal kurz in die Vase hier
und
später tu ich es dann in die Pflanze, okay?
Tamam?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Danke!
>> ELA: Ja, ich habe an dich geglaubt,
weil ich...
Ich habe an die geglaubt, weil ich dich so sehr liebe.
Also habe ich das schon mal mit Samira am Abend gemacht.
>> SALLY: Och!
O mein Gott!
Weißt du eigentlich, dass du so süß bist?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ach, Ela...
Eine Sauce Hollandaise,
müsst ihr wissen,
ist keine leichte Sauce,
also
nicht im Sinne von, sie ist schwer zu machen,
sondern
ist halt ein bisschen buttrig,
ist halt so eine Emulsion als Eigelb und Butter.
Also wundert euch jetzt nicht.
Ich habe sie nicht erfunden.
Das waren die Franzosen.
Und ich mache sie jetzt nur nach.
Dafür braucht ihr...
Aber komm, es trägt schon meine Handschrift, oder, Josh?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Die Sauce Hollandaise sollte eigentlich
Sauce à la Sally heißen.
Denn ich liebe Butter!
Ihr braucht dafür:
250 Gramm Butter,
drei Eigelb,
etwas Zitronensaft
oder zum Beispiel auch Weißweinessig
oder auch einen Schuss Weißwein,
Salz und Pfeffer.
Das war es.
Mehr braucht ihr nicht.
Die Butter wird jetzt erwärmt,
aber nicht heiß, sondern wirklich nur handwarm.
Ihr könnt hier auch Butterschmalz nehmen.
Das ist nämlich dann schon geklärte Butter.
Ich erhitze sie jetzt hier in diesem Gefäß,
damit ich sie später gut ausgießen kann.
Ich werde jetzt
solange
hier schon mal Wasser kochen.
Ich mache es jetzt hier ganz klassisch auf einem Wasserbad.
Ihr könnt aber auch eure Küchenmaschine nehmen,
eine Kenwood zum Beispiel
oder bei der KitchenAid
gibt es ja auch
die Schüssel mit präziser Temperatureinstellung.
Hier kann ich schon mal das Wasserbad erwärmen,
also das Wasser drin kochen,
und die Eigelbe in die Schüssel geben.
Und da braucht ihr jetzt eine temperaturfeste Glasschüssel
oder auch eine Metallschüssel.
Ich gebe die Eigelbe hier in die Rührschüssel.
Ich kann auch schon direkt Zitronensaft dazu geben.
Wie gesagt, Weißweinessig könnt ihr auch nehmen
und noch ein bisschen Weißwein.
Also so ein bisschen Säure braucht ihr auf jeden Fall.
Salz
und Pfeffer.
Und jetzt
einen Stabmixer.
Und auf dem Wasserbad erwärmen.
Und da achtet ihr jetzt drauf, dass das Wasserbad,
also das Wasser die Schüssel nicht berührt,
und erwärmt es jetzt hier.
Ich nehme doch meinen Schneebesenaufsatz.
Ich wollte meinen Schneebesenaufsatz nehmen
und dann habe ich mir gedacht:
"Nee. Komm, ich nehme einen Stabmixer."
Mhm. Ich nehme einen Schneebesen.
Weil die Menge ist einfach zu klein für den Stabmixer.
Und jetzt immer schön rühren,
damit kein Rührei entsteht.
Und wenn ihr das jetzt in der Küchenmaschine macht
mit Hitzefunktion, einfach auf 78°C erwärmen.
Schön weißcremig rühren.
[Musik]
Sobald die Eigelbmasse dann cremig ist,
kommt jetzt die Butter mit dazu.
In einem ganz dünnen Strahl wie bei Mayonnaise sozusagen,
damit sie nicht gerinnt
und das Eigelb das Fett schön aufnimmt.
Also wirklich ganz, ganz langsam.
Das Eigelb wird dann auch gleich dickflüssiger.
[Musik]
Fertig.
Also ich muss ja echt sagen,
privat mache ich es nur in der Küchenmaschine,
in der Kenwood.
Da muss ich nämlich nicht am Herd stehen und rühren.
>> MURAT: Wieso hast du es so gemacht?
>> SALLY: Um es zu zeigen, wie es ohne Maschine geht.
>> MURAT: Ach so. Okay. Alles klar.
Seht ihr?
Dass nicht jeder sagt,
man braucht für immer alles eine Maschine.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: So kann man es natürlich auch machen.
Ist etwas umständlicher, aber es geht.
>> SALLY: Guck mal.
Nicht umständlicher, aber man muss halt dran stehen.
Guckt einmal.
Eine perfekte Sauce Hollandaise.
>> MURAT: Und woran merkst du das, wenn es nicht so...
>> SALLY: Weil die so schön, guck mal, so dickflüssig ist,
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: nicht geronnen.
So. Ist das eine vegane oder normale?
>> SALLY: Das ist die normale.
Und ich habe mir jetzt als Tipp abgeguckt
in der Gastronomie,
beim Jamie Oliver habe ich mir das abgeguckt,
>> MURAT: Woah, ist das cool!
>> SALLY: die füllen jetzt die Sauce
– weil die muss man jetzt eigentlich sofort verzehren.
Die ist jetzt bereit. Die muss man sofort verzehren.
Und die füllen ihre Sauce in Thermoskannen ab.
Richtig cool, weil dann kann er sie
einfach bis zu zwei Stunden aufbewahren für seine Gäste.
Und ich habe mir jetzt gedacht,
ich habe keine Thermoskanne
und Thermoskanne auf dem Tisch
ist jetzt nicht so schön.
Ich habe jetzt hier meinen Gusseisentopf genommen,
den mini.
Achtung!
Heißes Wasser rein. Warum?
>> MURAT: Warum?
>> SALLY: Damit er warm ist.
Jetzt ist der Topf warm.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Ah, jetzt habe ich es kapiert.
>> SALLY: Uh, ist der heiß!
Jetzt ist der Topf heiß.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ich schütte das Wasser weg.
>> MURAT: Ach so, du willst nur den heißen Topf haben.
>> SALLY: Ganz genau.
>> MURAT: Hätte man den nicht auch
in den Backofen reinstellen können, den Topf?
>> SALLY: Nein.
Dann wird er nämlich zu heiß.
Das Ding ist halt, die ist jetzt schön warm,
aber, bis jetzt mein Spargel fertig ist, auf dem Tisch ist,
ist sie einfach zu kalt.
Also fülle ich das jetzt hier rein.
[Musik]
Also die halte ich jetzt kurz warm
und zeige euch jetzt noch,
wie man die vegane Version macht.
[Musik]
So. Die Kartoffeln sind vorgedämpft.
Der Spargel kommt dazu.
Wir mögen ihn eher al dente.
Also nicht zu lange dämpfen.
[Musik]
Für die vegane Version nehme ich
100 Gramm vegane Butter,
50 Gramm Mehl, etwas Kurkuma für die Farbe,
Gemüsebrühe,
Senf,
vegane Sahne,
Salz und Pfeffer.
Wenn ihr diese Sauce etwas fettreduzierter machen wollt,
könnt ihr auch einfach nur 40 Gramm Butter nehmen.
Ich habe es jetzt mit rein,
weil ich einfach auch
diese cremige Konsistenz haben möchte.
Fett ist auch Geschmacksträger.
Vegane Butter jetzt vielleicht nicht so unbedingt,
aber Fett im Allgemeinen schon.
Jetzt schön hier schmelzen.
Im Prinzip ist es eine Béchamelsauce vegan
ein bisschen anders aufgepimpt.
Ja.
Das war es.
Schön die Butter zerlassen.
[Musik]
Ich brate das Mehl jetzt so etwa eine Minute mit an.
Hier kommt jetzt die Gemüsebrühe rein.
Und wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr auch hier gerne
ein bisschen Weißwein dazu geben
oder für eine leichte Säure auch einen Weißweinessig
oder Spritzer Zitronensaft.
Dann die vegane Sahne,
Kurkuma für die Farbe natürlich,
da das Eigelb jetzt hier fehlt,
und mit Salz und Pfeffer abschmecken.
Den Senf gebe ich erst zum Schluss dazu.
Denn der verliert einfach seinen Geschmack
durch das Erwärmen.
Und jetzt lasse ich die Sauce aufkochen,
leicht eindicken
und dann ist sie fertig.
Und die kann man dann auch ganz gut aufheben.
Die könnt ihr auch gerne
noch am nächsten Tag erwärmen und essen.
[Musik]
Jetzt richten wir an.
Die Spargelspitze oben ist immer das Highlight.
>> MURAT: Okay.
So.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> MURAT: Das probiere ich jetzt auch mal.
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Lecker.
>> MURAT: Lecker.
>> SALLY: Und ich habe ihn
sogar nur fünf Minuten gedünstet.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Denn ich mag Spargel,
wenn er so ein bisschen Biss hat.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Boah! Wahnsinn!
>> SALLY: Megalecker!
Also Sauce Hollandaise
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: supergelingsicher, wenn ihr die Tipps beachtet.
Wie gesagt, nicht überhitzen
und
einfach sofort servieren.
Mir ist sie schon fast zu kalt, denn
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: wir haben zwischendurch Fotos gemacht.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Daher stand sie jetzt 15 Minuten.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Aber ansonsten, wie gesagt, einfach schön
im Töpfchen warmhalten oder
in so einer Thermoskanne.
>> MURAT: Lieber Hartmut,
ganz, ganz liebe Grüße!
>> SALLY: Richtig lecker dein Spargel!
>> MURAT: Schade, dass du jetzt nicht da bist.
Gerade in der Zeit
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: geht es leider nicht anders.
Aber wirklich ganz, ganz toll!
>> SALLY: Ganz toller Spargel!
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Ich hole jetzt noch
den Volkan.
>> MURAT: Genau!
>> SALLY: Und vegane Sauce Hollandaise!
Für dich, Volkan!
>> VOLKAN: Hi!
>> SALLY: Probier mal!
Gut, wir hatten sie vorgestern schon.
Da hast du sie schon probiert, gell?
>> VOLKAN: Ja.
Die war trotzdem lecker.
>> SALLY: Und?
>> VOLKAN: Super!
Saftig.
>> SALLY: Ich liebe Spargel!
>> VOLKAN: Hm. Ich auch.
So fresh.
>> SALLY: Und man merkt wirklich,
dass es frisch gestochener Spargel ist,
weil er wirklich so knackig ist
>> VOLKAN: Hm.
>> SALLY: und einfach so einen Biss noch hat.
Cool, gell?
>> VOLKAN: Richtig lecker!
>> SALLY: Perfekt!
Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich noch die Suppe machen,
aber ich glaube,
das sprengt einfach den Rahmen des Videos.
Deswegen werde ich die Suppe für uns morgen zubereiten,
packe jetzt den Spargel schön ein
in so ein feuchtes Küchentuch,
dann kommt es in den Kühlschrank.
Morgen gibt es bei uns die Suppe dazu, morgen Mittag.
>> VOLKAN: Hm.
>> SALLY: Mache ich auch vegan für euch
und normal für uns
>> VOLKAN: Danke.
>> SALLY: mit Butter.
Ich finde, Butter ist halt der Geschmacksträger schlechthin.
>> VOLKAN: Ja, das ist anders.
>> SALLY: Nicht? Butter schmeckt anders.
>> VOLKAN: Butter schmeckt anders,
>> SALLY: Also ich hoffe,
>> VOLKAN: geiler.
>> SALLY: euch hat das Video gefallen.
Und vielleicht habt ihr ja
das eine oder andere über Spargel dazugelernt.
Wie gesagt,
meine Message in diesem Video ist einfach:
Kauft den Spargel bei euch vor Ort
von eurem Bauern, von eurem Landwirten!
Unterstützt eure Region!
Dann bekommt ihr zum einen die beste Qualität
und ihr unterstützt die Menschen, die dort arbeiten.
Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüssi!
>> VOLKAN: Tschau!
[Musik]